[Music]
manga movie adaptions don't always have
an easy time with critics when you also
attempt to do it as a live action film
there are often vast differences between
what the audience imagined and the final
product nevertheless there are also
surprises every now and then such as
alita battle angel by robert rodriguez
the film about the cyborg elita was more
than impressive which is why fans are
eagerly awaiting a second part the
screenwriters would have plenty of
material for it since the movie only
deals with the first two volumes of the
nine part manga besides there's still an
alternative ending with battle angel
elita holy night and other stories that
can be told yet how realistic is the
second part actually and what could it
be about these are the questions we deal
with in this video
it is true that the story of the first
movie unfolds very quickly and by leaps
and bounds especially gathering momentum
at the end therefore we have briefly
summarized the most relevant aspects if
you haven't seen the movie yet and would
rather avoid spoilers you should skip
ahead now elita is a cyborg girl who was
found and resembled by dr dyson idol in
the scrapyard of iron city after finding
out that her father is not only a doctor
but also bounty hunter also referred to
as a hunter warrior she wants to join
him to fight against the evil cyborg
assassin ruska plus she finds the love
of her life in a human name hugo he
wishes for nothing more than to go to
zellum the big wealthy sky city that
hovers over iron city as the movie
progresses elita learns not only that
she is a former elite fighting machine
with hidden powers but also the hugo has
been robbing cyborgs and cannibalizing
them for the motable tournament of a
powerful man named vector in order to
earn his way to xalem in the
confrontation with grueska and his
allies hugo ends up being severely
wounded by the honda warrior zepen alita
and chiron dr ido's ex-wife can only
save his life by turning him into a
cyborg as well thanks to charon alita
finds out that vector is basically
controlling the whole city as well as
the assassins thus she sets out to
confront him once she arrives she
realized that he too is merely a puppet
being controlled by the powerful
scientist nova from zelen wanting to
stop her the latter sends grushka after
her again however she can easily defeat
him using her new equipment and zapin's
sword thereupon she kills vector and
ends the conversation with nova by
telling him not to underestimate her
hugo meanwhile is desperately trying to
get to xalem elita tries to stop him yet
he is shredded by the city's defense
ring months later alita is the star
athlete of the motable tournament as the
crowd cheers she points a sword towards
xalam while nova watches her from there
possible storylines can of course best
be derived from the original manga from
the early 90s the first movie deals with
the first two volumes and partly with a
third volume the latter is about elita's
rapid rise in motorball after hugo's
death she tries to put her life assho
hunter warrior behind her and rather
deal with her grief here the second
movie could tie in nicely in general the
fast plot development could also shed
some light on sequences from alida's
earlier life but above her past and the
motorball career is of course the issue
of xalem what does the skycity actually
look like and who lives there besides it
was teased at the end that the brains of
some adult humans were removed for
instance from vector and chiron by
inserting microchips instead nova can
gain control over people's minds and
bodies but just how many of these
zombies are there in iron city after all
nova is presented as the real villain at
the end of elite battle angel that
doesn't necessarily have to be the case
though in fact in battle angel alita
last order alita nova joined forces in
xalam making him one of the most
important allies she has of course this
raises the question of who's actually in
charge and pulling the strings behind
the scenes in addition there's a honda
warrior that we definitely need to keep
in mind for a possible second part
zapin has had the most sacred thing for
him ruined by elita namely his face he's
surely out for revenge while stop at
nothing to get it the fact that he's
unscrupulous was already shown by the
man in which he used hugo to make alita
a target ultimately stabbing him to
death it is conceivable that he will
join forces with a powerful enemy from
xalam as they attempt to hunt her down
and the manga one character appears
which we would particularly like to see
in the second part chaos who has
psychometric abilities he can learn
everything about his counterparts passed
by a mere touch and the manga he thus
becomes an important person when it
comes to working out alita's warlike
backstory he's also the one who detects
and terminates this special dependency
between xalum and elita something that
surely some fans can also envision is a
prequel that mainly deals with elite's
early life the manga series battle age
lolita mars chronicle is about exactly
this period though not only about the
great war of that time but also about
live on mars and earth and the troubles
between the two planets we notice that
there's definitely enough material if
robert rodriguez and james cameron are
going to make another movie we can
assume that they will mostly be inspired
by the original manga and battle angel
alida last order the storylines differed
too much from what was aimed for in the
first film after all because even though
the director stated in an interview that
he considers the film and the story to
be a concluded story arc there is still
a lot to be told in our opinion
well enough of the big talk let's get to
the most important thing what are the
prospects for a second part here two
opinions differ we will focus on the
facts in the united states the film
grows just about 85 million us dollars
with production costs of nearly
175 million us dollars the movie managed
to make up for that with a worldwide box
office result of 405 million however the
rather weak earnings prompted 20th
century fox not to make a sequel for the
time being shortly afterwards fox was
acquired by disney and the film has been
available in disney plus since july
producing partner james cameron further
revealed that there are already over 600
pages of notes which only need to be
evaluated director robert rodriguez who
has taken a great liking to the
franchise would also be ready for a
second part even though he regards the
storyline as finished it is evident that
there is still more than enough to tell
about the young cyborg lady the growing
fanbase around the whole project would
also speak in favor of this similar to
justice league with the hashtag
schneidercut more and more fans in the
online community are demanding a sequel
to the film with the hashtag elitist
sequel however disney has not expressed
any opinion on the matter yet it is also
worth mentioning that
is currently working on or at least
collaborating on at least four other
projects so it seems that on the part of
director we won't be seeing a sequel
anytime soon however one should never
say never after all there is more than
enough content to be found in the manga
and if we're being honest we would like
to see the story of elena told even
further
that was our original to elita battle
angel 2 but let us ask you guys
something how badly do you desire a
second part or is your opinion the same
as rodriguez that the story of the first
movie is already a good finished one we
believe this should be at least one more
film and the prequel would be great as
well if you have any more story ideas
feel free to share them in the comments
and if you enjoyed this video thank you
see you next time
[Music]
you